there's there is a kid who his his job
it is like people employ him to when
they can't get me for stuff they employ
him to look like is this this guy is it
you've met him
hey that's not cool that was like a
doctor picture of you oh really
no wait here you are together yeah
I've managed to grow a little bit of
facial he looks like you looking into a
spoon they are Cudahy when I filmed the
Bridget Jones film I could only do one
day instead of two so they're casting
for the second day no he actually cops
off with Bridget's making it so many
people post pictures particularly quite
beautiful women post pictures thinking
that they've met you and sometimes like
I was just a fat dude it looks a bit
drunk that's kind of like that I didn't
want to say that but you're right I mean
some of these are quite Rafi like med ed
sheeran last night
happy to see them
[Applause]
imagine you didn't have a deprived
childhood but when you when you made
money
free free never when you made money when
you made money
you you you bought certain things and
you that stuff that you
yeah we're denied as a child yeah like
what did you buy well I wasn't tonight I
wasn't know any good parent will know
any parent in here if a kid wants a Lego
set you get them in a small one you
don't get in the big one that's like 359
quid so when my album went to number one
I was passing the lego store the big
Death Star and I went I'm just a big kid
now it isn't just it isn't just that
it's like I went to go buy my
goddaughter a ninja turtle Tori for her
birthday and then I was in the Ninja
Turtles section there was a huge a ninja
turtle truck and I was looking at the
small toy I got for her in the big truck
and all that up getting that for me you
like the kid from big yeah I have a load
of child stuff in my house there's a
roomful of teddy bears this went on a
date and brought a Lego set and made the
Lego set and then left
she was eating your dinner and you were
chatting just kept catching up now it
wasn't though which an innovation
definitely be watching this being like
yep definitely happened what did you
make part it's the Caribbean partnership
I hope you gave it to us a gift to the
your little well just because what we
read in our papers oh yeah I got a car
so this was the was it you think rugged
right it was JT was James James Blunt
China get his pop career book the papers
I don't know there wasn't a lot of
people there that night so you can say
allegedly what happened okay allegedly
one of the princesses
Eugenia Beatrice one of them and James
Blunt and Ed Sheeran we're in a room
zooming in a palace James blood
allegedly wanted to be knighted is that
a euphemism and so one of the princesses
found a handy sword item did you not
read this in the papers what I didn't
know James Bond was involved up to that
point anyway it was a bit of swordplay
and Ed sure and got caught the face is
that right no I I have no idea how that
story came out I have no idea cuz it's
like it was so tight it was and like for
like two weeks afterwards I had this
huge gash on my face and people would be
like Oh what happened you'd be like I
fell
it came out because entering you now
went on your gap year I guess it was
kind of a gap year yeah
did you know how long it was going to be
when you went on because what did you so
you came off social media I I got rid of
my phone completely still I have a phone
she tried some decent way to sober up on
that no it's good I got I got bought an
ipad but now I just do emails okay so I
got rid of my phone completely and then
it was like I want to go to the
countries where I've been to and Talde
and only seen a dressing room a venue
and a bar and then so Australia was one
of those what like I've never been to
the Sydney Opera House or like gotten to
Barrier Reef properly or even like Gold
Coast or anything so I rented a mini and
drove up the coast and then I did like
New Zealand and in Japan for like two
months Iceland which is great everyone's
you go to Iceland yep
there was a lot of death wish I feel in
your in your Iceland was the death wish
I put my foot in a boiling geezer
upper-upper volcano I was walking up all
this mud on my 25th birthday and I went
to Iceland to see the Northern Lights
and I got when I was the top of a
volcano and we're kind of walking around
and they were like right don't go off
the path because it's dangerous I was
like okay didn't really clock it and
then I saw a little like little pool of
water that was kind of bubbling no
that's quite cool volcano bubbling over
there I had an experience where you felt
like you're gonna die but it literally
like went slow motion I was like that's
I was earning steel-capped timberland
boots so it slipped in and I kind of
fell on the side and pulled it out and I
just felt melting and I was like oh my
god screaming Scooby screaming and they
were like don't take it off don't take
it off and I was like why and I took my
sock off and all the skin came with
[Applause]
helicoptered out and they put a skin
graft on it because there's literally no
no skin and I'm kind of like shaking
like this in bed like China gets better
but I'm kind of like oh man and then I
just pass out and then I wake up to the
tannery of the hotel being like right
there it is folks the greatest sighting
of the Northern Lights in the last 20
years that won't be happening again for
a while there is folks pretty it's
pretty pretty bad but it's yeah yeah it
kind of just kind of looks like that and
take your word for it hi what's your
name James James dr. James and what do
you do
I'm a civil servant a civil servant
nobody in London here yes in London are
you from the London air no I live in
London but I'm originally from Suffolk
oh it's a Suffolk massive is he
mentioned in the song probably yeah No
what school did you go to um so I went
to Brandon oh sweet yeah well I with the
promis'd primary school okay did we know
each other yeah
[Applause]
James hello yeah James yes me that's the
one and now you're talking to him
honestly he's right oh my god can we not
flip them and just get them out of here
do you have a story or do you boy yeah I
did but it's leaves let it be about okay
sorry
then we'll flip you and then okay cool
yeah yeah when we were younger ed used
to come round to my house and yell at
you saying we used to be quite good
mates and I remember one time one time
he was coming round for tea and I've
forgotten to tell mum who's a vegetarian
at that point anyway and so mum cooked
I think the sausage and mash for tea and
Ed said you know after the meal these
are the best sausages I've ever tasted
you know where did you get them from a
mum had to lie because she had no clue
sorry first of all I ever had me and
also the first time I ever watch The
Simpsons episode was around you and we
could be reunited backstage
[Applause]
Renda me have a seat have a seat
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh we've got time for that reunited it's
beautiful
[Music]